the U.S confirms the MQ-9 Reaper drone
has been regularly deployed over the
Black Sea which has become an
increasingly crowded airspace but a
pentagon spokesperson says this is the
first direct air confrontation since the
Russian invasion of Ukraine what we saw
again were fighter aircraft dumping fuel
in front of this UAV and then getting so
close to the aircraft that it actually
damaged the propeller on the MQ-9 we we
assessed that it likely caused some
damage to the Russian aircraft as well
the Russian defense Ministry has a
different version of events insisting
the Drone crashed after maneuvering
sharply while approaching the Crimean
Coast
the Russian Ambassador was summoned to
the U.S state department and afterwards
he gave what seemed to be more a
justification than a denial
this uh drum can carry 1007 100 kilos of
explosives
this drone can carry a few booms you see
that what will be reaction of United
States if you see such Russian drone
very close for example to San Francisco
or New York what will the reaction of
United States
a national security liaison officer at
the White House echoed the Pentagon in
describing the Russian action as
Reckless and unprofessional confirming
the president was informed straight
after the incident
the key issues say U.S intelligence
sources whether the Russian Pilots were
acting unilaterally or under command
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington